so I'm just to confirm my computer says
that we are now live can you just
confirm that's correct you're on your
confirmed moment yes Thank You Sonia
thank you very much welcome to Oxford
District Council's first remote
executive meeting and welcome to anyone
work watching on the via the live stream
just so everybody is aware agenda item 9
has been withdrawn and will be dealt
with by the licensing committee moving
on we have a number of non members of
the executive members attending I've got
this is good counselor mrs. Gooding
that's what George ironin I so mrs.
Christine Mason councillor Mike Michael
Hoyt council counselor mrs. Loraine Shaw
and counselor mrs. thumley I think that
is all just can you confirm that makes
us nobody else councillor Eve's as well
councillor mr. Reeves swear to that list
as well please if you had minutes of the
meeting held on the 4th of March are you
happy that I signed them as an accurate
record grade great what anyone to the
country
thank you to receive declarations of
interest item form if obviously if
anything should come up during the
course of the meeting can you make it
none of these okay next item that we
have on the agenda is item 5 which is
questions on notice from counselors and
first council I have on my list here is
counselor mrs. Christine Mason and her
question is to the portfolio holder of
Finance counselor Simon Smith counsel
mrs. Mason would you like to put your
question please please confirm the
amount received from central government
to assist with the situation adviser
Smith would you like to respond thank
you Sonia is just about to put a table
on the screen for everyone to see and
the take the table sets out the
breakdown of how the counsel is
currently anticipating its grant
allocation of nine hundred and two
thousand one hundred and seventy pounds
to be used this is based on the
financial return to the mhm CLG
which is the ministry of housing
communities and local government that
return was made in May and that was
previously circulated to all members
this represents the council's best
projections of income losses and costs
over the course of 2021 but will be
subject to review and refinement as the
financial year progresses and the
figures crystallized I'm just not quite
managed to get the table Sonya can you
switch your mic off because we're
getting feedback from the YouTube
channel as it's coming over y'all right
a speaker
just one will wait just one waiting then
I'll start to go through some of the
headings until the figures actually
present themselves so the first line
will be mitigation against loss of car
park income these at these are in value
order five hundred and forty thousand
six hundred and seventy five additional
temporary accommodation costs one
hundred and twenty three thousand one
hundred and six IT resilience 24-hour
availability costs one hundred and two
thousand mitigation against expected
loss of Building Control income fifty
one thousand six hundred and nineteen
mitigation against expected loss of
planning income twenty eight thousand
one hundred and twenty five leaflets to
publicize the community hub thirteen
thousand four hundred and twelve
mitigation for leisure services income
twelve thousand six hundred and seventy
mitigation against expected loss of
licensing income thirteen thousand one
hundred eight additional waste
collection costs five thousand pounds
software related to business grants four
thousand five hundred pounds
business grants administration cost
three thousand seven hundred eighty
Facebook advertising campaign for
business grants two thousand pounds
emergency food parcels one thousand
pounds IT server works one thousand
pounds other three hundred and seventy
five so that's the total allocation
received on trench's one and two
totaling nine hundred and two thousand
three hundred and seventy pounds so if
we are unable to get this table out we
shall ensure that it is circulated to
all members promptly Thank You mr. Smith
any issue there
as the managing director ease aware I
have problems with technology and I
can't always access the information
that's given it in that in the format
I'm still waiting for the council to
return resume paper copies but thank you
for that this is nice and do you have a
second good question thank you thank you
very much indeed for your time thank you
the second question we have is from
counselor mr. hoi Ennis to the portfolio
holder for finance councillor Simon
Smith hi would you like to put your
question please yes Thank You chairman
this is for the portfolio Hall Durham
councillor Simon Smith on page 7.15 of
item 7 financially outrun 2019 220 item
P ro 25 payment to local suppliers
within 10 days he's indicated as red
with only 56.4% paid within that time
compared to the target of 90% the
year-to-date figure is sixty two point
seven percent to the same target this is
very disappointing to see as cash flows
of the utmost importance to small
businesses particular as this was
leading into the shutdown of missing
many businesses due to the virus the
reason given is given a staff changes
however good system should not allow
this to happen what has been done to
rectify this to bring the payments to
the target of 90 percent or above have
the payment times improved since the
report thank you thank you
so Sam Smith the council only has one
officer who deals with payments and this
role is currently covered by a temporary
member of staff well unfortunately was
not made fully aware of the look that
local supplies should be prioritized for
quick payment the officer is also
dependent with the rest of the council
raising and receipting orders in a
timely fashion to allow for these prompt
payments to take place in addition that
the processes and the structure of the
team are planned to be reviewed shortly
which will include ensuring the roles
and
of individual offers officers are set
out clearly and appropriate performance
monitoring is carried out so we do
expect payment times to improve in the
future thank you capsule hi have you a
supplementary question Thank You
chairman I'll probably have many
soccerberry questions then you're
allowed only one I'm afraid though I do
know that don't worry I take on board
what them cancer Smith has said and I
will just watch with interest the next
quarterly report thank you may I give a
supplementary answer Hugh Smith yes
please
um just the this particular target it's
not a target that is prescribed
centrally it's a target that we as
accounts on decided was important a
number of years ago and and obviously we
are working towards that but just for
for members flow the reference when we
term local suppliers were not just
thinking particularly with him not for
district we are taking that wide of you
so local businesses do include Rochford
district thunderously them fleet can be
Southend hardly Lee West Cliff and
sugary so I hope that gives Council high
a little bit further confidence that it
is something we we take seriously and
the actions that we're putting in place
will hopefully ensure that he doesn't
see red against that local that local
decision target next time around
thank you my chairman council hi and now
you're only an out one set for mentary
not a supplementary question Kevin I
thought I thought that's what that was
I'm afraid though use a sacred I didn't
have a sub debate to your question and
then there's a sake low simply making
statements so I took I took that as a
question I'm afraid
counselor mrs. Lumley I do notice that
your hand is up I'm sorry to say that I
can't take any questions from
non-members
unless they are on notice so just so
you're aware of that particular point
just say in relation to a declaration of
interest earlier I'm not can I mention
it at this point as a County member I
may have an interest in item eight with
the provisions in that item as a County
member for a town center division
counselor women Williams I noticed your
hand is up is that a declaration of
interest as well no it's the question
for Simon Smith you for Mac you know
yeah the particular point can take
questions for members from members on
notice can you put your question to him
outside of the meeting place oh yes
thank you
okay the next item on the agenda is item
seven which is a paper from the
portfolio holder from finance councillor
Smith I think it you're going to
introduce that Thank You Jamie just a
reminder for clarity this is last year's
and end of your run so this this period
that we're talking about finished at the
end of March
so although the the kovat issues had
started there they didn't really impact
on on last year so do do bear that in
mind but as a year I feel that this
report covers another successful
financial year for Rochford District
Council I fact him if I got it believe
that the council was successful in a
large number of air
finance is just being one of them there
are a number of recommendations that I
shall ask ar-15 rotten officer to go
through in a in a short while but
through a variety of economies through
our staff working exceptionally hard
dynamically and innovatively when there
were staff vacancies to be filmed we've
come up with a surplus at the end of the
year there are movements in our
surpluses and no me will go over those
one particular thing would like to point
out is that our capital program did
under spend it didn't understand for
efficiencies it under spent because we
weren't able to deliver all of those
projects and we are undertaking within
the first quarter to review that
situation to ensure that what is
allocated is capable of being spent so
that that's something that is coming up
in the pipeline
I did mention briefly the the Cobie
situation and saying that this report
doesn't cover that but I think it is
important to note that we could not
foresee what was about to happen what
has happened what is happening but what
is certain is that the council was in a
good position to approach something like
this because of its effective financial
management
I'll now pass over to our r15 one
officer Lucas to continue thank you
Thank You councillor Smith and as
councillors missus said these extra
velocity and consider the provisional
out turn position for 2019-20 the the
reason it's called provisional
is because the accounts for the year are
still being finalized and therefore
subject to review and scrutiny by our
external external auditors but this is
our our best estimate of the position at
this stage and where we're not expecting
significant movements from that as
councillor Smith has already alluded to
and we didn't feel a material impacts of
code mid-nineteen in the 2019-20
financial year but we will obviously be
keeping the close monitoring of that
position into the 2021 financial year
and wisconsin smith said we have a
healthy level of reserves and balances
to support us in our financial
sustainability the detailed revenue
position is set house at paragraph 2.2
if the report which you'll find on page
7.2 that sets out the position by
portfolio and it sets out the original
budget for each portfolio area the
actual amount that was spent in in year
to give the variance under spend or
overspend and before any use of
pre-approved use of reserves which have
been agreed in year and before any carry
forwards which are asked to be a
previous part of this report to be cared
for did to 2021 the net position after
those movements is an under spend of
four hundred and eighty nine thousand
two hundred and eighty pounds and before
the reserve movements that were approved
as past its quarter three the corporate
movements for specific purposes which
brings us down to a small underspend
of 118 thousand three hundred and
seventeen pounds the the underlying
position of four hundred eighty nine
thousand is
a small change compared to the quarter
three position where we were projecting
and underspend of five hundred and
seventy one thousand pounds that the
predominant factor in driving on spend
remains the same which is set out in the
second table on page seven point three
which sets out the salary under spends
and that remains the predominant driver
for the understanding year at four
hundred and seventy two thousand pounds
however there are a number of other
variances by portfolio which are also
detailed in paragraph and two point
three the Reserve's position assess
houses appendix one on page seven point
seven that shows that our opening total
balance of reserves stood at nine point
five million and after accounting for
transfers in and outs and has resulted
in a year-end position of ten point two
million so a relatively modest increase
of about seven hundred thousand pounds
which is mainly due to the new homes and
bonus monies which we plan to put into
reserves and then there's also notice
that we are forecasting to draw down
around three million of that over the
next financial year so our jected
balance for the end of next year is just
over seven million pounds and we do feel
that due to the fact that many of those
reserves
we're earmarked for specific purposes
anyway and the risks particularly around
kovat and our general financial
pressures that we're facing that that
remains a prudent and suitable level of
reserves for the council to hold at this
time
members would also like to note the
capital position for the year which
councillor Smith also referred to that
is detailed at appendix 2 on page seven
point nine
so the carry-forward requested for the
2019-20 financial year is just over 1.7
million pounds against a final and
capital budget for the year of 3.2
million pounds as councillor Smith
mentioned we will be taking a review to
ensure that the monies carried forward
from this financial year in addition to
the monies approved in the 2021 and
budgets at full council in February that
those programs remain achievable for us
in the financial year and yeah as I say
to ensure that they can be delivered and
it may be that we re profiles on the
base and programs as part of the quarter
one and financial monitoring for the
next 100 year appendix 3 sets out the
carry of the revenue carried forward
requests in a greater number of detail
it's broken down into two areas
so the first table is the grants and and
specific carry forwards and totaling
three hundred and fifty nine thousand
pounds on page 7.1 to those those monies
are held for specific purposes and can't
be used for anything else so there's
limited choice in terms of the council
half uses those monies the table on the
second table on page seven point one
three is for more general and carry
forwards which are not ring-fenced in
the same way but nonetheless individual
service areas have got some specific
intentions to use those money during the
next financial year and if therefore
requested that those monies are carried
forward to enable and specific pieces
and work or projects to be completed the
last appendix is the performance and
report as a quarter four and I think the
indicators are relatively
self-explanatory so they are that
appendices to notes and little C if
members have got specific questions
around any of the indicators happy to
try and answer those as well so I think
that covers the main areas of the report
if members would like I can go forward
so I go through the specific and
recommendations and one by one but I
would probably advise that the
recommendations are taken together
unless members have any specific
questions they would like to ask myself
a consciousness before they for the
recommendations have put forward thank
you Cashman Smith you have your hand up
yes so could just come back briefly
German just to mention the the reserves
and some of the capital items as Nomi
said a good number of those are
ring-fenced and can't be spent on
anything else so it is important that we
review what we're doing to ensure that
we can spend them but it's also
important that we do have those reserves
because you can't you can't be little on
the situation that we're in but
ultimately life is going to go on the
council has to progress its initiatives
its ideas and its business and so it is
appropriate that even though we're in a
situation that is quite unprecedented
that the council still prepares for the
future that the council's is still got
the its ability to carry on its normal
business and to deliver projects for the
benefit of residents in our community
thank you
members of the executive are there any
questions for either counsel Smith or
for the one five one off so now I have
nobody showing at this point so I'm
assuming there's no questions to make
sure no I mean would you like to go
through the various the recommendations
so members are fully aware and publicly
aware of the recommendations members
just to confirm are you happy that I
take the recommendations as a whole is
there anybody that doesn't wish me to do
that as a whole please chairman nobody
wishes me not to take that okay know me
if you'd like to read through the
recommendations please yes thank you
chair and so the first recommendation is
and one point one is to note the
provisional out turn position against
the 1920 revenue budget as contained in
paragraphs 2.1 to 2.3 the second is to
note that the council's 2019-20
statement of accounts are still being
prepared and will be subject to audit by
the external auditors Eli
it is therefore possible that changes
may be made to the accounts during this
period which could alter the position
presented within this report the third
is to approve the transfer from the
business rate smoothing reserve of six
hundred thousand and four hundred and
ten pounds which is set out in paragraph
two point three of the report under the
heading non service specific expenditure
the fourth recommendation is to approve
the transfer from the pensions reserve
of sixty three thousand pounds which is
set out in paragraph two point three
under the heading of the finance
portfolio
the fifth recommendation is to approve
233 thousand eight hundred and eighty
seven pounds of revenue carry forwards
requests which are set out in appendix
three the sixth recommendation is to
approve three hundred and fifty nine
thousand six hundred and ten pounds of
Revenue grant funded carry forward
requests which are set out in appendix
three the seventh recommendation is to
note and approve the earmarked reserve
closing balance at 31st of March two
thousand twenty twenty including those
rolled forward as grant funded and
ring-fence projects as per Appendix one
the eighth recommendation is to note the
final out sown capital position against
the 2019-20 capital budgets as contained
in paragraphs two point four five and
shown in appendix to the ninth
recommendation is to approve 1 million
seven hundred and sixty eight thousand
one hundred and eighty-five
you
the final 2019-20 position on the
council's key performance indicators as
shown in appendix 4 you heard the
recommendations there now with regards
to the voting the voting will be done by
a whole call of names will I call out
your name
will you please clearly indicate whether
you wish to have a recorded vote and
then whether you are voting for or
against or abstaining on the
recommendations going forward so I'll
start with - councillor FD no recorded
votes and for counselor mrs. Rowe no
recorded votes for Chairman Thank You
mr. Smith a recorded vote and for as a
step time itself no recorded vote and
for this award no recorded vote and for
chants and we couldn't hear
no recorded votes and for Ashley
Williams there were no reported votes
and four and counselor wouldn't no
recorded vote and four Thank You members
of my list
and just perhaps difference thumbs up
from Sonia I take that as unanimous
thank you it's an eight which is in the
hands of the portfolio hold up for
Enterprise Chancellor wooden would you
like to and present your paper please
Thank You chairman well the paper is
before you and this is about the
reopening of our high streets safely
fund this is our share of the 50 million
pounds Fund nationally our share is
seventy seven thousand eight hundred and
thirty six films and it is about making
sure that we reopen our high streets
safely for the benefit of residents and
businesses
this report is of course at the
governance report but reflects in part
that work has already started because we
are aware that our high streets were
open at the start of this week so of
necessity some of what is being talked
about in this report has already started
and there are essentially four strands
of activity and those are set out on
page eight point two and eight point
three and the principal activities are
to support and develop an action plan
and how the local authority may begin to
safely reopen their local economies a
communications and public information
activity
business facing awareness and temporary
public realm of changes but to ensure
that we opening of local economies can
be managed successfully and safely so
those are the four strains the outcomes
of how we're proposing to spend this
money are set out on page 8.4 and are
very clearly there for us to to see from
three points one zero through two point
one six now and the whole the whole
reports is supported by an action plan
again that set out on page eight point
seven appendix one so that is how we
propose to spend the money in so forth
so that is really the report and the
first I use and as I said a little
earlier it's easy in the large part or
in certain parts a bit retrospective
because actions can be effective in this
and had to already go in place and a
very impressive information pack which
I'm holding up at the moment was
produced and circulated to all of our
businesses a website was opened on
Wednesday of last week and a
considerable amounts of public safety
signage has already been placed around
the district and the idea to have a
branding to this I believe was a first
for Rockford and the highest form of
flattery is when you see other boroughs
or districts copying it and we are back
which is our branding seems to have been
copied but I take that as flattery on
the excellent branding before I conclude
Kevin I just want to say a particular
thank you to all the people who over the
last two weeks have put in a tremendous
amount of effort and work under the
guidance of our system director Marcus
Bachmann
but it's a large number of people right
across the officer spectrum keeping me
very much in the picture but thanks to
the economic development team other
officers and to our local suppliers who
have supported us brilliantly in
delivering this the first part of this
program so unless there are any
questions over person recommendations
channel which I'm sure you will let you
like as they come and the my
congratulations to the team that you
just mentioned they're on the world can
get you off the ground as quickly as
they did and for it to work so well it
has been it has been very very well
adopted or loudly the whole of the
district and I think businesses I'll ask
the assistant director place and
environment hardwood white do you wish
to add anything to the to the report
you're on mute so I think you mean San
Marcos each other I do apologize well I
think outlined the report quite failures
and there was that an issue I think
experiences that we had to undertake I
think just to uh I think get good value
for money I think it's too late I think
we'd be doing expenditure after so the
horse has bolted so it was important
that we did swing
I think tension to is the appendix when
he's very much just an outline
expenditure and I suspect this will
change over time the action plan is
actually underpinning behind that he's
now quite a living working document that
ties into many of the stakeholders
around districts and I imagine the
expensive will change and more
over time as we sort of understand more
of what's required in managing the high
streets of course are those outcomes and
that action plan will be consulted with
the portfolio hold for enterprise or a
regular basis happy any questions thank
you I have my hands up chairman thank
you thank you it's just a big thank you
please to all the officers but in
particular today on behalf of the town
council to the environmental health
officers that have been to visit the
town today had a good meeting with them
and our deputy Clark they are doing a
great job and they've helped us
remarkably with the market situation
thank you okay any other questions from
members council Williams Thank You
chairman you're likewise I just want to
congratulate others and they do this but
most excellent thank you
anybody else I can't see anybody council
wooden your hands up Thank You chairman
I should come back and it's always
difficult when we start passing out
thanks but various agencies have worked
extremely well on this and I should have
also mentioned the various parish
councils it's been real teamwork to make
sure the parish councils as well as
Radiesse Town Council and one thing we
are looking at which is worth mentioning
chairman is that we are cat with the
experience we're seeing so far we feel
that perhaps a 20 mile an hour speed
limit restriction on a rainy High Street
might be something that we want to
activate in the future for the safety of
residents who have been perhaps used to
quads or streets now they're getting
busier and there may be a safety need
but we're keeping that under review at
the present time Jim
absolutely I want to rain on increase
parade that's just one observation our
district is our district is
more than muttered Rayleigh and Hopley
with halbridge pork well great Wakering
darling who's all got shops and we're
still not on the website so tonight
please be rectified
thank you Jake the assistant director
will take a note of that and take that
back
of course yes sorry if I may explain we
burn in many ways again what underpins
this is it's almost a very large risk
assessment of the districts and so you
know in terms of prioritizing we've
identified the areas a higher priority
and we're working through by do take
your points in it is actually we hope to
have in place by this week thank you
thank you
is there any other questions nobody else
okay I'm not sure whether councillor
wooden or whether Marcus you wish to
present the recommendations on your
paper delegate assistant director place
of environments in consultation with the
portfolio holders french fries to enter
in tone our HSS grant funding agreement
with the cities and local growth units
seal GU sealed U is a joint unit between
the depart of business energy and
industry strategy and the ministry of
housing communities and local
governments I think we're going to take
all these four together last question
the second markers but carry on
is it the second decision is to agree
the proposed spending plan for the
councils are HSS grant allocation of a
maximum of seven thousand eight hundred
and thirty-six pounds assessed and
appendix one of those reports Siddim
three is that authority be delegated
assistant director place and environs in
consultation with the portfolio old
friends price to all contracts that's
really our our HSS grant funding
agreements in line proposed spending
plan and the final recommendation is
that the decision be taken to matter of
urgency and not subjects calling because
the need to ensure that outcomes
to meet the initial deadlines are the
majority shops reopened in a week
commencing 15 to June 2020 echo Marcus
members are there anybody that does not
wish me to take them as a home as before
members voting will be done by roll call
of names when I call out your name
please indicate if you wish to have a
recorded vote and then whether you are
voting for or against or abstaining on
the recommendation go through my list
again counselor FD no recorded votes and
for now mrs. Rowe no recorded votes and
for chairman Joseph Smith no recorded
vote and for okay gasps a step to
herself man called evoked and for reward
no recorded vote for Jimmy absolutely no
recorded votes and for chairman Castle
Williams Thank You chairman no recorded
vote and for councillor wooden no
recorded vote and for chairman thank you
thank you
members called it to my list I believe
that to be unanimous if I can have a
thumbs up from German that is correct
okay members thank you very much indeed
members like you just want to
acknowledge that we were joined during
the course of the meeting by two other
visiting members that's council Stanley
and council of AIDS so if that can be
rotated I don't think I've missed
anybody else but Thank You councillor
Weston do apologize cast on just see
your thumb pop up there okay um members
I think that my successful as a our
first executive zoo meeting and I thank
you all for your time and wish you
rested
thank you very much for your time Kevin
ladies Thank You chairman
good evening to the initial chairman